est à présent l'heure de lire la presse
au vu de précigné sandrine gomez bonjour
sandrine bonjour philomuses nous
revenons à la une de la presse ce matin
sur les annonces des manuels macro ans
sur la filière nucléaire civile le
président français veut notamment
construire six nouveaux réacteurs ppr
wifi lomé avec une mise en chantier du
premier réacteur ep air d'ici à 2035
alors il ya effectivement beaucoup de
réactions dans la presse ce matin on va
tout d'abord jeter un oeil à la une de
mediapart qui titre vous le voyez la
fleur au fusil emmanuel macron annonce
la renaissance du nucléaire français ici
on nous dit que le gouvernement a tout
simplement oublié fukushima onze ans
plus tard il est écrit la sûreté des
réacteurs semble être redevenu un sujet
secondaire dans l'espace public et puis
on rappelle aussi le retentissant fiasco
2 le p r de flamanville dix ans de
retard et un coup et multiplié par 6
c'est à dire 20 milliards d'euros
critique aussi dans le journal la croix
qui déplace le débat ici sur le terrain
de l'atome et de la démocratie qui avant
de vous qui avons-nous un temps entendu
hier s'interroge le journal catholique
le président le candidat dans le premier
cas il s'agit d'une annonce dans le
deuxième cas c'est plutôt une promesse
de campagne pour des décisions aussi
structurant en tout cas la bonne marche
pour le journal de la démocratie et bien
ne serait plus 5 des parlementaires je
cite s'empare du sujet une fois passées
les prochaines échéances électorales
et c'est le cas figurez-vous en suisse
où se débat le sujet du nucléaire et
bien il est au coeur d'un débat public
relancé par deux grands partis udc parti
conservateur et les libéraux du plr les
annonces de macron nous dit ce journal
dans l'édito montre bien que l'atom n'a
pas dit son dernier mot le temps mais
ton garde ici attention aux chimères
nucléaire ce sont des annonces qui vise
à flatter un électorat emmanuel macron
je cite le président joue ici la carte
électoraliste à quelques semaines de la
présidentielle m emmanuel macron
l'importante toujours pas candidat et
oui en philo mais il n'est toujours pas
candidat il reste deux mois tout juste
avant la présidentielle
alors la presse de droite elle s'en
offusque un peu ce matin regarder cette
une du figaro macron veut encore gagner
du temps alors le journal qui montre ici
un peu l'impatience des français il
s'était d'ailleurs un sondage som
sondages au doxa selon lequel 68% à des
françaises souhaitent aujourd'hui que
emmanuel macron se déclare dès
maintenant on attend 1 nous dit-on dans
l'édito macron comme on attend godot le
journal qui cite ici à beckett dans
l'édito et qui conclut personne n'a
jamais gagné une bataille philo mais en
essayant jusqu'au bout de l'éviter
autres sujets dont la presse
internationale c'est cette attaque dans
un parc naturel au bénin sandrine
commerce attaque dans laquelle français
a perdu la vie oui alors le parquet
antiterroriste français a ouvert une
enquête après la mort de ce français de
50 ans dans une embuscade dans ce parc
au bénin c'était mardi une actualité
vous le voyez à la une d'aujourd'hui au
faso qui titre sur une nouvelle
incursion meurtrière de terroristes dans
ce parc qui rappelle ce quotidien
constitue une frontière naturelle entre
le bénin le burkina faso et le niger
attaque qui a visé une équipe de rangers
de sept personnes tuées cette personne
c'est la tacc donc la plus meurtrière
depuis le début des incursions
terroristes dans ce pays en 2019 s'il
attaque n'a pas été revendiquée le
quotidien en tout cas explique que les
regards se tournent vers la katiba mme
hasina l'a poussé djihadistes longtemps
cantonné au sahel déploie ce je cite ces
miasmes vers le golfe de guinée le site
burkinabè outre si toi qu'as tu verras
wakat serra estime que le bénin vous le
voyez ici a mal à son or le pays va-t-il
également se laisser déposséder nous
disent journal de son or comme d'autres
pays africains notamment ceux du sahel
qui risque de perdre le leur le nord
toujours s'insurge ce site d'information
c'est une preuve de plus ici encore de
l'expansion du terrorisme dans le golfe
de guinée des pays comme le bénin la
côte d'ivoire et le togo sont désormais
aussi dans l'oeil du cyclone alors enfin
un autre journal burkinabè cette fois le
pays qui lance ici une mise en garde
temps que la riposte ne sera pas
conjointe entre le niger le burkina faso
et le non pour traquer ces terroristes
ces derniers auront toujours la latitude
de frapper là où ils veulent quand ils
veulent il est temps nous disent journal
de que la cedeao sortent enfin de son
long et à je cite toujours entre
guillemets végétatif pour aider les
états en proie au terrorisme à sortir de
cette impasse sécuritaire il pouvait
fermer votre revue de presse en ligne
comme elle on va jeter un oeil sur un
journal russe le moscow times qui
revient sur l'histoire d'un jeune russe
en visionner pour s'être entraîné au
terrorisme sur minecraft oui il
s'appelle nikita ou var up et il a 16
ans il a été condamné à huit clos par un
tribunal de sibérie à cinq ans de prison
pourquoi regarder cette une du moscow
times pour complot terroriste visant à
faire exploser le bâtiment du fsb ce
sont les services secrets russes de
minecraft c'est un jeu vidéo il a donc
été condamné pour avoir projeté de faire
exploser un bâtiment virtuel ses deux
co-accusés ont donc écopé de peines de
prison avec sursis car ils ont coopéré
avec les enquêteurs alors ici le moscow
times cite notamment des militants des
droits de l'homme qui estiment que cette
peine sert à créer philo mais une
atmosphère de peur chez les jeunes qui
critique qui critiqueraient je vais y
arriver le gouvernement
merci sandrine de metz c'était la revue
de presse d'un